what's going on guys we are over halfway
through calendar year 2015 and we've
seen a lot of movies so far we've eaten
a lot of popcorn and we formed a lot of
opinions today we're gonna talk about
movies that we've loved and hated and
we've got a pretty cool panel of movie
aficionados to talk about it with first
he is a critic at large for the Nerdist
Kyle Anderson welcome back Kyle thanks
ray I'll be back he'll see you buddy and
cheap film critic for the LA Weekly Amy
Nicholson yeah so let's talk about top 5
throw me one that's on your list one of
your favorite movies of the year Kyle
one movie that I thought was just came
out of nowhere just kind of surprised me
with how much I enjoyed it was Kingsman
which was just so silly and fun I'm not
a big fan of the Roger Moore Bond movies
but I was a big fan of them pretending
to do Roger Moore Bond movies collect
the send up of the thing more than the
thing yes yes sort of I like I like the
whole style of it I never thought I
wanted to see Colin Firth kill 100
people in a church but now I'm really
glad I have what's one on your listing I
love spy that was great
because I'm really invested in Melissa
McCarthy's career and I feel like people
do not understand what to do with her
she's loud and she's funny and she
doesn't fit into a stereotype and
usually they put her in a comedy and
they just hit her with a car and make
her like the joke right here this is a
movie where she's smarter than anybody
else in the film and she's awesome she's
hilarious she's the best spy in the
whole movie she's perfect at her job and
it the whole movie is just about
people's perception of her and how
they're wrong so Kyle give us another
movie that you loved from this year so
far um I was a big fan of the horror
movie it follows it was taking an old
type of genre which is the slasher movie
kind of making it supernatural not
explaining anything and just making it
scary where did you stand on it follows
I love the idea of it follows because
there's nothing scarier than the idea
that no matter where you are or what you
do or where you go there's a thing that
will come and kill you I guess it's
gonna happen to all of us eventually
when old age oh wait what no you're
never gonna die Helen's okay thank you
continue
I loved all of that but I just wanted
them the rest of the movie to be as
smart as the idea throw us another film
that you like from this year there's a
film called what we do in the shadows
this is a fake mockumentary
about all of them living as vampires in
a house in New Zealand and they're all
different ages it's like the real world
but hugely generate
there's like a person who's 8,000 years
old and then a vampire who's like 180
and he's like the young punk kid gosh
it's really bloody too cool so there's a
couple that you like so far what are
some movies that you walked away from
that theater having to take a shower
after uh Amy here's one that really hurt
to hate because it's a sequel to a movie
I really like Hot Tub Time Machine 2 mm
I love talk to Time Machine 1 I saw it
three times it came out I saw that the
drive-in I loved oh wow I bet the
drive-in makes any movie better it kind
of does except for me theose Oh first
one had great Edie 80s hair metal and
this one had nothing all right Kyle
what's another movie that you know you
would have rather have put acid in your
eyes than m-z I saw a movie called the
boy next door which helped Jennifer
lópez's yes it was clearly edited from a
pg-13 movie down to an r-rated movie any
thoughts on boy-next-door
yeah I didn't see it but I actually kind
of wanted to it's I mean it's worth
seeing if you like scrap but basically
what's another movie that made you angry
I really don't like insurgent sequel two
divergent the whole idea of divergent is
insane it's like you're either smart or
you're kind or you're like generous and
then there's this idea that like if
you're a person who combines all of
these traits you're divergent but that
should be the word convergent and this
just drives me insane that means like
nothing right Wow that's double dome uh
cheek I'll well somebody has to talk
about it yeah so let's let's talk about
Mordecai this movie would have been
great if Terry Thomas had been in in
1963 but he wasn't and they didn't make
it then so it's terrible Johnny Depp is
trying really hard to be British and
like the most British person of all time
I don't even remember the plot of it
really but it's it's all about him
running around and Paul Bettany looking
like he could clearly be in a better
movie I caught elect know what okay okay
great let's shift gears let's go back
let's cleanse our palates and talk about
a couple of films that we enjoyed this
year that are in our top 5 so far
halfway mark Kyle talked to us um I
really really like the sci-fi movie ex
machina oh yeah that movie was great
I really like the fact that it's it's
such a small cast there's really only
three characters it's really a fantastic
movie Alex Garland writer director
good um another film that you like from
this year Amy I really liked aunt Minn
actually top five liked I'm going to put
it in top five for a specific reason I
have seen every more of a movie of
course you kind of have to every Marvel
movie in almost every superhero movie if
you don't solve this last thing the
entire world is going to extract uh-huh
and when have you ever seen a movie
actually be like cool let's let the
world explode Annan keeps it really
small to where maybe something bad could
happen
and by reducing the scale like literally
and then also just with the script yeah
I think it makes the superhero movie
feel fresh again what's another one that
makes your top 5 Pixar's inside out oh
yeah boy howdy did I enjoy this movie
man yeah so they made a movie that was
exploring topics that kids probably will
get but parents I think will really get
a lot out of and just what a nice
message telling kids it's ok to be sad
sometimes that's important yeah ah sad
is as important as happy yeah let kids
yeah I thought that was great they're
selling little action figures of sadness
right to be so fascinating yeah is like
carrying it around as an adult I carry
my sadness with me all the time
Amy what's another film that you're a
fan of that makes your top 5 it's called
the voices and it stars Ryan Reynolds
have you guys heard of this song yeah
he's like a serial killer yeah Wow it
has a talking dog and a talking cat so
if you're not sold talking dog talking
cat and then Ryan Reynolds killing
people it's amazing
let's move back to hate Kyle I don't
like to say bad things about Liam Neeson
ever cuz I like Liam Neeson sure I hated
taking three I thought it was the
silliest movie I've ever seen none of it
made any sense he just murdered all
these people and then at the end it's
like oh you weren't you're not a bad guy
after all he's too smart for this there
are some ends two trilogies that are
like this is the triumphant finale to
this three movie series this was not
that
no what's another movie that you got to
give the thumbs down to this year if
we're gonna talk about action movies
where a hero we love actually acts like
a horrible person then I have to go with
San Andreas whoa whoa whoa shots fired
our vet you know I cannot support this
decision I will not get behind this you
can have your piece I'll let you say
your piece but Rock big fans here you
don't want to see a guy who looks like
no one you know in real life saving the
day
you want to see a guy who looks like a
normal dude saving the day because
that's probably what's gonna have to
have we had that it was called 2012 with
John Cusack and it wasn't great and
believe between John Cusack and the rock
I'm what the rock coming in to save me
but here's the problem the rock is not
gonna come to save you because you're
not his daughter he is a first responder
yes yes job is to save people you look
in the back of that movie and you see
people saving other people who aren't
the rock oh I understand you watch that
movie and you want to fire him from his
job what's another film that upset you
enough to put it on your top 5 least
favorite movies I have trouble even
saying anything about this cuz it's so
dumb but they put so much money into
Jupiter ascending and it was just a
nothing it was just just a big bowl of
nothing yeah
it's not good I am hating it I don't
like it when a movie takes that many
insane risk yeah yeah but it's terrible
no we should should be scrubbing toilets
at the end of the film
Amy another one that's on your that goes
in the crap bucket for you I said
something nice about Ryan Reynolds and
now I have to pick on a movie starring
his wife the age of Adaline Blake Lively
plays a woman who when she's 29
falls into a freezing lake and then gets
struck by lightning and so she never
ages lives for 107 years invests in
Xerox stock is like a millionairess many
times over and then we're supposed to be
really sad for her character the whole
time like oh why can't she grow old and
die and she just like hangs out pouts I
mean cuz honestly like I think any one
of the three of us would be happy if we
are frozen in the body of Blake Lively
and like never died uh dreams coming
true
let's cleanse the palate let's talk
about the best of the best what is your
favorite film of the year so far number
one with a bullet with several bullets
yes some gasoline is a Mad Max fury road
guzzoline guzzoline yes apologies that's
my number one what why would i shake ass
pound it boom blow it up yeah it's a
movie that is so simple it's almost
ridiculous if you try to break down
someone the plot of this movie it is a
woman driving down a road and then turns
left when she's not supposed to that's
the plot of the movie and then they turn
around and just come back that's the
movie it's about as simple as possible
yeah the scene I always think about when
I think about why I love this movie so
much yeah is the one where Mad Max is
trying to use a long gun to shoot at an
oncoming
are and he gives her the gun and she
takes the shot and she makes it and what
that seam doesn't have is what any other
dumb action film would have put in told
you I'm amazing I'm a girl everybody
talked about it and this movie's just
like cool she's good at this and then it
goes on yeah it all worked together so
well is just a visceral fun ride now
let's talk about the opposite of that
Amy Nicholson start with you your least
favorite film of 2015 so far there was
some competition for this mm-hmm and I
had to go with the cobbler it is a movie
where Adam Sandler plays like a virginal
dude who just hasn't met the right girl
who's also a 48 year old who works in a
shoe store where he like fixes shoes for
a living if he puts on a customer's pair
of shoes he becomes the customer and so
what he does with this is basically
nothing good we ask both of you to guess
what the box-office gross of the cobbler
was Kyle I'm going to say four million
dollars Amy I'm gonna say two million
dollars 24,000 odd 24,000 more than it
deserves Kyle
worst of the year my least favorite
movie was called strange magic that's
the correct response just to this it was
a let me remind you a computer-generated
jukebox musical written by George Lucas
what exactly I'm here this [ __ ] was a
dream you guys are looking at me like
I'm making it up and I wish I wish I
have okay we're trading cuz now I need
to see it yeah it's bad it's real bad
Wow Wow
what are your favorite movies of the
year so far what are your least favorite
movies of the year
tell us your top five or your top one in
the comments section below best answer
we're gonna send you a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my awesome panel
Kyle Anderson check them out on the
Nerdist Annie Nicholson check out her
reviews LA Weekly thanks for being here
you guys absolutely and thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye
any possibility of seeing giant man in
the future listen I think you know with
Hank Pym and Scott Lang and that
technology I think it's safe to say at
some point somewhere you're gonna see
some some
real growth for bel-air